[Music]
on this Saturday night
the first pope to resign in 600 years
dies at the age of 95. a look at the
unusual Legacy of Pope Benedict XVI this
was a loving holy man tributes for a
trailblazing journalist is this news to
you no no it's not news how Fearless
interviewer Barbara Walters is being
remembered by the generations of
journalists she Inspired Real Estate
forecast the wild card that Canadian
economists will have their eye on in
2023
philanthropy at any age you don't have
to be rich you don't have to be super
smart you just have to be kind the
nine-year-old cancer survivor being
recognized for her generous spirit
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight Sonya sunder
former pontiff Benedict died today just
days after the public was told the
95-year-old health was declining in his
first public comments his successor Pope
Francis called him a gift to the world
and described him as Noble and kind the
pope will preside over his funeral on
Thursday to be held in Saint Peter's
Square
good evening and thanks for joining us
reaction to the former Pope's death is
pouring in from all over there are mixed
feelings about Benedict who was
extremely conservative in his views his
leadership also happened at a time when
the Catholic church had a reckoning over
abuse Eric Sorensen takes a look back at
his life
Pope Benedict XVI made history as both
first and last the first pope in 600
years to retire from the papacy and the
last in a Thousand-Year succession of
European pontiffs Joseph ratzinger was
ordained a Catholic priest in Germany
almost 70 years ago a church scholar he
was appointed Bishop of Munich as
Archbishop under Pope John Paul II
ratzinger LED the powerful congregation
for the doctrine of the faith which
ultimately dealt with the sexual abuse
by priests
I will
wear that
we know that he had a
had a handle and mishandled this really
serious issue Benedict tried to show the
church as modern and relevant he was the
first pope to tweet and the first to
place a call to astronauts in space yeah
astronauts I'm very happy to have this
extraordinary opportunity
but he also steered the church on a
traditional path opposing abortion
divorce and gay marriage
he sought to restore Faith where it was
threatened by secularism
but there was nothing traditional about
his decision to retire it was unheard of
in modern times he in a very human
moment admitted that the the onerous
task of the papacy was too much and that
he would resign
and make way for the election of a new
pope yet living on as Pope Emeritus his
presence challenged his successor the
more liberal Pope Francis
was tolerant of gay marriage
who am I the judge he said but Benedict
in the later biography viewed gay
marriage as part of an anti-christian
Creed throughout this period the church
sex abuse Scandal continued to widen
we're in control this will never happen
again conservatives used the Scandal and
the views of Benedict to undermine
Francis Benedict not only blazed a trail
for future popes to retire but to find a
new position of power in the Catholic
Church doesn't set up an alternate
Center of authority let's say in in the
Vatican so I think that the way that
retired popes live and speak and have a
public presence will be one that's
questioned in the future
Pope Benedict has given the Catholic
Church much to think about and a highly
unusual Legacy the pope who Reign and
the pope who resigned Eric Sorensen
Global News
Canadian members of the Catholic Church
are also reacting to the death of Pope
Benedict Cardinal Thomas Collins says he
will be remembered as a shy and
scholarly man
well I think he will be remembered as a
great Pope as the Greek leader spiritual
leader very holy man but I think in a
very particular way
his writings will continue down for
centuries and centuries yet to come I
would not be surprised if he's called
what we call a doctor of the church one
of the great teachers like St Thomas
Aquinas or Saint Teresa of Avila or St
John of the Cross and so that's the way
in which he has helped us and I think
that will continue especially
Canadian Cardinal Mark wallet also
commenting on Benedict's death tonight
in Rome telling media he was a man who
was able to reflect on the relation
between faith and the evolution of
culture Benedict's body will lie in
state and Saint Peter's Basilica on
Monday until his funeral
now to another loss being felt around
the world tributes are pouring in for TV
Pioneer Barbara Walters she died Friday
at the age of 93. Walters was a Fearless
interviewer known for asking tough
questions to some very famous people
Jennifer Johnson looks back at the
extraordinary career of Barbara Walters
Barbara Walters built a career of first
she was the first female co-host of
NBC's Today Show the first female to
co-anchor a network nightly newscast
Barbara Walters and she hosted what is
still one of the most watched television
news programs ever her sit-down
interview with former White House intern
Monica Lewinsky about her affair with
former President Bill Clinton why did
you tell Linda Tripp about this dress
because it was funny
it was funny throughout her career
Walters proved she had the grit to ask
the tough questions and never winced
when she got back uncomfortable answers
it wasn't an affair it wasn't love it
sex Walters never shied away from
grilling disgraced politicians world
leaders and beloved celebrities
including Princess Grace Johannes I must
ask you the question that most Americans
want to know about you are you happy
tributes to Walters have flooded social
media Oprah Winfrey writing without
Barbara Walters there wouldn't have been
me basketball great Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
tweeting Barbara Walters never flinched
when questioning the world's most
powerful people she held them
accountable Katie Couric writing her
body of work is unparalleled and Tennis
Superstar Billie Jean King calling
Walters a true Trailblazer
launched the talk show The View in 1997
which is still on the air on the day she
signed off fellow journalists honored
her for Paving the way for their own
careers in an industry once dominated by
men this is my legacy these are my
legacy her Legacy also included a slew
of Emmy nominations and wins two
lifetime achievement awards and her own
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame I'm
Barbara Walters and this is my show the
10 Most Fascinating People Walters was
the woman who got to ask the famous
questions we all wanted to ask and
brought those conversations into our
homes
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
breaking news out of Ottawa tonight
starting next week the federal
government will require covid-19 testing
for travelers coming into Canada from
China Hong Kong and Macau the measures
follow similar rules from other
countries including the U.S and Japan as
China grapples with a surge of the virus
Canada's new measures come into effect
on Thursday
many people around the world are already
celebrating the new year with loved ones
but those in Ukraine are doing so under
the shadow of Russia's War another wave
of Russian missiles struck the country
on New Year's Eve damaging residential
areas and killing at least one person in
Kiev as ukrainians enter another year of
enduring moscow's Invasion Sean O'Shea
has more
foreign
facing 2023 still defending a Russian
invasion the end can't come soon enough
I would really like this year to be over
says Oksana morozenko finding Joy here
isn't easy
it's New Year's that it makes me feel
sad her mother chimes in
as Russian airstrikes once again fall on
Ukraine
president of Vladimir zielenski said the
world will never forgive the terror
Ukraine said we'll never forgive Russia
a Moscow Russian President Vladimir
Putin drank a toast with soldiers and
gave out medals
his defiant defense minister claims
Russia's Victory like the new year is
inevitable while Ukraine's defense
minister released this video a letter to
Santa thanking the West for weapons and
asking for more I hope you don't mind
that we generously shared some of your
gifts with our deranged Northern
neighbor
behaved very badly this year
Russia and Ukraine did exchange
prisoners in time for the new year 82
Russians and 140 ukrainians seen here
and other soldiers many fighting since
February came home by train to Kiev for
New Year's we spokes teeth and really
close the atmosphere and candles and
candles
just to be together just us nothing else
the country's Collective hope
Tamara kovalova says Ukraine wants
Victory and peace
as it enters to culminating one full
year at War Chantal Shea Global News
still ahead the state of Canada's
housing market
what's in store for home buyers next
year
[Music]
this year started with a bang at least
in terms of home prices but saw a major
shift as interest rates went way up and
gaviola has a preview of what's in store
for the Canadian housing market in 2023
the housing market is closing out 2022
with a whimper November saw nearly 40
percent fewer home sales compared to the
year before and 13 percent fewer than
the 10-year pre-pandemic average I'll
pull out my crystal ball and take a look
drawing on 25 years worth of experience
this real estate brokerage owner says
the Calgary Market is poised to see
prices climb in the first half of 2023
as Alberta's economy booms attracting
buyers for more expensive areas in BC
and Ontario we have so little inventory
anecdotally I was talking to a realtor
this morning that said she's finding
more and more buyers are writing backup
offers on property simply because there
is such a lack of inventory across
Canada Royal LePage expects the median
price of a single-family detached house
to Fall 2 percent to 781 thousand
dollars and a one percent price slide
for condos to nearly 569 thousand
Toronto and Montreal area prices
forecast to Fall 2 percent Calgary and
Regina down one and a half and Vancouver
down one percent even though the cost of
borrowing has soared high savings and
high employment rates can keep home
prices from falling too much if you're
one of those people who has been
listening to some of the Bears from
other sectors who are suggesting home
prices are going to drop 30 or 40
percent you may be disappoint the the
math just doesn't work real estate
analysts don't expect big changes in the
Toronto area housing market realtor
nazma Ali describes the market right now
as extremely slow people who don't have
to sell aren't but if interest rates
keep soaring or if the economy Takes a
Tumble the market could take a turn for
the worse and if it continues this way
we're probably going to see more houses
and condos and listings hitting the
market for sale whereas what we've seen
so far is not enough desperate people to
sell most experts expect a return to a
more seasonal pre-covered Market where
prices and activity pick up in the
spring and gaviola Global News Toronto
coming up a look at a year of advocacy
on missing and murdered indigenous women
girls and two-spirit people have the
calls to action been answered
[Music]
thousands of indigenous women girls and
two-spirit people have gone missing or
been murdered in Canada and many of
those cases were not properly
investigated by police the stories of
victims families across the country came
to a head earlier this month in Winnipeg
where an alleged serial killer was
charged four indigenous women are
believed to be his victims they are the
latest cases in a national tragedy
Advocates say isn't being met with the
urgency or resources needed nitugacha
has a look back on some of their efforts
over 2022 and their calls to action
more than 100 people gathered in
Winnipeg on December 4th calling for a
national state of emergency to be
declared for missing and murdered
indigenous victims there's a two-tier
system in Canada you know that's really
rooted in structural and systemic racism
there's one for non-indigenous people
and there's one for indigenous people
Advocates here have long believed serial
Predators frequently Target indigenous
women girls and two-spirit people now
they're combing through the cases of
those who remain missing throughout the
province wondering how many more died at
the hands of alleged serial killers like
the one handed four first-degree murder
charges a few weeks ago two of the
bodies are believed to be buried in a
local landfill which police say they
can't search alone leaving grieving
relatives pleading for help my mother
didn't pass away with the home so let's
pay her the respect
that she deserves by finally giving her
one that's not a resting place at the
Prairie green landfill Cambria Harris's
mother Morgan is one of at least 10
indigenous women killed in Winnipeg this
year
in northern BC this notorious stretch of
highway 16 is known as the highway of
Tears on account of the multitude of
indigenous women and girls who were
murdered or have gone missing while
traveling along it signs are still up
with their posters and a warning for
girls not to hitchhike when Greyhound
pulled out it was it was just a blow to
everybody in Canada especially western
Canada there are ongoing calls for a
national reliable and affordable bus
system the most vulnerable that may not
have the the connections or you know not
have the money that end up hitchhiking
and that's that's a that's a very real
threat it's still something that we need
to contend with Mary TG is helping
direct the BC government's commitment of
nearly 10 million dollars for a Highway
16 action plan it includes expanding
Transit options using Community vehicles
through a grant program and installing
web cameras and bus shelters that action
plan I think ought to be an Exemplar
across Canada but they also should be
looking at that action plan for the rest
of the province of BC red dresses have
become a symbol for action and awareness
according to Stouts Canada nearly 1 in
10 victims of a violent crime in 2019
were indigenous women whose homicide
rate is six times higher than that of
non-indigenous people each woman
deserved their own cover story a Toronto
non-profit created this newspaper
featuring four thousand cover stories
honoring their lives we also wanted to
define the magnitude in the physical
paper itself the paper weighs about 25
pounds and that really demonstrates that
if you capture the true story of each
indigenous woman who has been missing or
murdered you would see the heaviness of
it it was delivered to the prime
minister's office in the fall calls to
urgently act on recommendations from the
2019 inquiry into missing and murdered
indigenous women and girls have remained
unanswered those calls include appeals
to create a national indigenous and
human rights ombuds person and a
tribunal I hate to say it and I didn't
want to go there but you know if it
wasn't indigenous women with this uh
with would this already be happening you
know because it's indigenous women is
and girls into spirit and gender diverse
is is this why it's taking so long a
spokesperson for the crown indigenous
relations Ministry told Global News in a
written statement it's committed to
accelerating efforts to implement the
national action plan the federal pathway
and the calls to Justice and that in
January a national Roundtable is being
convened by the federal government and
there will be an update on the calls for
an ombuds person and a tribunal the feds
also say they're providing funding to
the assembly of Manitoba Chiefs for a
feasibility study of the Winnipeg
landfills
some also want to see accountability
from the Catholic Church which ran many
of Canada's residential institutions the
issue was taken to the Vatican in the
spring
Advocate Lorelei Williams says she paid
her own way to Rome during the
indigenous delegation meetings with the
pontiff in hopes of raising awareness
I've been out there on the front lines
speaking about this so much nobody
really listens to me because I'm at the
bottom of the Barrel in Canada
indigenous women are at the very bottom
she did the same in Edmonton when the
pope came to Canada I feel like the pope
is not touching on it at all back home
in Vancouver she helps families search
and fight for justice for their loved
ones Wilson says they formed a coalition
but have few resources everybody just
volunteers their time so I'm thinking of
you know the women that go on searches
I'm thinking of the women that take up
the role to do victims assistance I'm
thinking of the women and Elders that go
to the courts
some Advocates here call it a clear
National crisis and wonder why it isn't
being treated like one
meetugarcha Global News
[Music]
if you or someone you know is in need of
help or support you can call
1-844-413-6649 this is a national
toll-free Crisis Line available 24 7 for
anyone who requires emotional assistance
related to missing and murdered
indigenous women
[Music]
next a child cancer survivor gives back
The Young Alberta girl that's being
recognized for her fundraising efforts
[Music]
a young Alberta girl is being recognized
for her generous Spirit despite fighting
a battle of her own she has raised
thousands of dollars to help kids with
cancer and as Nicole Stilger explains
her philanthropy hasn't gone unnoticed
it's news that would rock any family the
worst thing you can ever hear is that
your child has cancer at six years old
Cecily Eklund was diagnosed with a brain
tumor when treatment started she wasn't
allowed to bring her beloved doll to
scans so she and Mom Kathy Eklund made
some that were MRI friendly she didn't
like going into the MRI machine without
anything and she found it very
comforting it's scary because it has a
lot of loud noises and you have to stay
still for
a long time Cecily thought it might
bring comfort for other kids going
through this too so she set out to make
more and ended up getting help from all
over the world we would have people send
dolls from Australia and Mexico and the
United States to help her build up a
whole stash of dolls to bring into the
stallery from there her philanthropic
Spirit only grew through a number of
different initiatives over the past
couple of years she's raised over
seventy thousand dollars for the kids
with Cancer Society a place that's been
there for Cecily and her family from the
start I like raising money because I
love I love giving back to recognize
Cecily's dedication and compassion the
kids with Cancer Society nominated the
nine-year-old for outstanding
philanthropist of the year which she was
ultimately awarded in November at the
national philanthropy Awards if I can
help even one child with cancer by
giving them hope that's the story I want
to tell Her speech included a powerful
message you don't have to be rich you
don't have to be super smart you just
have to be kind I couldn't have been
more proud
pretty pretty giving child today Cecily
is cancer free when you hit that
um relief of there's no tumor in the
skin you just you're just grateful and
even in survivorship the support from
the kids with Cancer Society continues
and so does Cecily's in March we're
doing a big birthday fundraiser to raise
ten thousand dollars Nicole Stilger
Global News
and that's global national for this a
Saturday night on this New Year's Eve
I'm Sonya sungar and from all of us at
Global we wish you a happy New Year and
on that note we will leave you tonight
with spectacular fireworks and vibrant
celebrations that have already happened
around the world to ring in 2023. thanks
for watching I will see you again
tomorrow good night
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]